Batman Batman Batman is it the cops of
what well [ __ ] so we look through the
window and it's the Mexican American guy
and he's like let me in let me in so he
schooled us right away he said look turn
the lights off turn the TV off you don't
need to flush the drugs they're not
gonna get in they don't have a warrant
they can't get a warrant that quick
there's too many apartments they knock
on the door just don't answer it yeah we
were all like thinking he's full of [ __ ]
they're probably gonna just knock the
door down any second
boy it did pass it didn't pass they came
and up and they went on and knock next
door and they went on their way so we
have a tense situation in this place
we're laying low and at the end of the
night he says look cuz you and your
friends protected me me and my brothers
have got your back and they had no idea
what that meant so few months later he
says one of my brothers wants to meet
you I go over to the street there's all
these lowrider showcase cars on the road
goes to the door his brother
answers the door he's gotta know her and
he's just looking at me scrunch in his
face you know he's just was just pale
skinny English guy he's brought all of a
sudden I imagine that's what he's
thinking I got talking and then he
starts buzzing off my accident he's like
damn you talk funny I guess you are from
England come in and meet my homies they
got the biggest TV I've ever seen in my
life they've got a little TV showing
like all the comings and goings on the
street outside in case the cops are
coming they're gonna know in advance and
then I did a double take because on top
of the TV I'm like alright I've seen one
of them before all in a minute yeah it
was in a Rambo movie they got a
rocket-propelled grenade launched on top
of the TV yeah so I knew I knew they
were lethal people I didn't fully
understand that they were the New
Mexican Mafia and so that was years
later when they were on the news and I
go over to
the brothers house I'm droppin the
Mexican guy off and the whole
neighborhood is black down and in the
police are out with light ones guiding
the traffic and they're all bringing
being brought out in by the feds in the
SWAT team it was news headlines that
night New Mexican Mafia most powerful
mafia in Arizona at the time killed
witnesses trying to kill police trying
to kill the head of the Department of
Corrections and I want to go carting
that rate basically I've been there a
little bit earlier so yeah that's how I
knew they were the guys who had my back
wow that's that's pretty incredible the
fact that you were mixed up with those
guys and at what point where were you
when you saw all this going down where
you had you already been locked up at
that point or were you where were you at
that point I started getting the EXCI
out of LA in the 1990s around 96 97
mm-hmm by 98 99 the people are bringing
the ex-ceo from Holland Sammy the ball
he got SWAT team raided and arrested a
year or two before me I got arrested
on may 16 2002